quick query halpert no way
still queer packer you can't put me down
too strong yeah dwight and jim tried to
get me
fired but i landed on my feet down here
in florida
you see this cat's got nine lives and a
night
captain i don't know if this is too much
but i got deputy chief brandt this
little basket of pears
they look ripe and crispy
hello raymond
[Music]
captain wunch good to see you but if
you're here
who's guarding hades it's deputy chief
watch now
unsurprisingly i've been promoted above
you and now i'm here to evaluate you
what happened to brandt he retired and
moved to charleston to be closer to his
grandchildren
so much for dying at your desk with a
little dignity interesting
i will attempt to cooperate with you
under these
new circumstances don't sweet talk me
halt
i gave it my best shot let's
begin and since my arrival
violent crime has gone down by 17.3
percent as you can see here
two-toned graphs you think you can
distract me from this precinct's
problems with a flashy presentation
same old ray halt fossil no steak
i'm off to do some spot checks
oh my god she's totally gonna flunk us i
haven't gotten enough since i failed
recess in second grade
teachers need a break too amy we were
doomed the minute she
slithered into the precinct it's funny
when we first met
we had some good times
looks like we both want that stapler
seems that way based on what happened
so when did it all go south 1989.
i was up for a big promotion which would
have fast-tracked my career
watch offered to write a letter on my
behalf but instead she torpedoed me
because
of something that happened the night
before she was to turn it in
madeleine
[Music]
would you care for a drink i'd love one
i'm sure you can tell
i'm quite drunk i've had a couple to
build up the nerve
i think we both know what i'm about to
say
raymond i don't think we need to say
anything
[Music]
i'm gay that's what i was going to tell
you
well then she sabotaged my career
because i refused to
bed her
oh
we've been telling that kid for a couple
hours i mean it must have been somebody
else
it was pochitis
believe me now that doesn't mean
anything to me
this is a peach pit okay he was eating a
peach when i went to go talk to him
this is his ace of spades this is his
calling cards this is what he leaves all
his victims
and it's still warm okay go and arrest
him and send us to the lab
we don't have a lab
[Music]
huh looks like andy's wearing him down
i'm gonna go finish him off
that is the dumbest thing i've ever
heard don't you just shut up for a
second
what's going on he's he's a jerk he is
being such a
jerk it's an awful thing to say to a
human being are you
crying no i'm not crying okay i'm
allergic to
jerks okay andy ouch fine i don't care
it's stupid
okay the gloves are coming off
what's that i think you know what that
is
when i came to visit you at the school
you were eating a peach
then my office gets vandalized and
somebody leaves a peach pit on my desk
i don't think that's a coincidence greg
wow you nailed me i mean there's no way
that two different people could be in
the same fruit
in the same day in the same area of
indiana
never mind that i was actually eating a
plum
when you saw me earlier
i know you did this i don't care what
you say i don't care that you were in
the parking lot all night
somehow you found a way to get in wait
wait how did you know that i was in the
parking lot all night because i
followed you genius if you followed me
all night
then you know that it wasn't me nope
what is your problem
look i've been very civil but i will
waterboard you
hey hey let's go man let them go
stay in the leadership
i am going to ring your neck how did you
get into the parks department
i have to know maybe the fbi can figure
it out
i'm not even in the fbi stupid wow
you're amazing you're going to jail for
a very long time
he's not going to go to jail you know
it's he's a minor well we'll let the
jury decide
there's not going to be a jury it says
then the judge will decide where he goes
look he's going to do probation
hey you know before i solve this case
i'd like to thank you for doing all the
super easy work you know the real nancy
drew level stuff
oh yeah did nancy drew solve a lot of
murders yeah she did murder on ice
recipe for murder nancy was a wonderful
detective i wanted to be her when i grew
up
thanks charles that's helpful hey should
we take odds on how
fast i'll solve this case no i mean what
was it with diaz's last
impossible extortion case what was it
six hours
that's because it was 98 solved the last
two percent's ours to get
that's why they leave it in the milk
what oh
wow looking good santiago gonna foxy ma
go rotten hell this is your fault
thanks champ good effort i got it from
here
and hey you feel free to call me anytime
you need me to come down here and help
powder that big white ass of yours
well that's the worst thing that's ever
happened to me oh man
this is gonna make a primo dump later on
well that looks delicious what is that
oh it's tom yung gong soup
it reminds me of when i was in thailand
rescuing victims of human trafficking oh
that sounds so good i mean i'm the
soup not the human trafficking oh and i
think your grilled eggplant looks so
good
should we with these
i can't believe you thought you could
pretend to be real eleanor she's like a
perfect ball of light and you're like a
wet pile of mulch someone made a person
out of wet mulch and leaves and like
dead slugs and that's you you look even
closer to death than usual
what happened to you very scared the
back of the b
train certainly was i had the whole car
to myself
so this is you figuring out new york
making the city worse for your own
selfish ends
is that your gym bag aren't you a human
woman
it's these new microfibers they keep you
dry
but it all has to go somewhere so
today a subway car tomorrow what
all in good time jack
will you take something for that cough
already i'd rather see if it gets better
on its own
do you want me to go on my antibiotic
grant it's endless you'll beg for death
there's a war going on out there and
you're gonna have to pick a side
i've always wanted to say that and i
can't believe i have wasted it on you
you've crossed the line lemon
[Music]
someone's gonna stop you new york is
gonna stop you
the old liz would have agreed with you
but that was two days ago
now i don't cross lines i just make them
disappear
[Music]
stop the clock oh speaking of the devil
ladies and gentlemen the devil dennis
feinstein
hang on now leslie i think everybody's
going to want to hear what i have to say
thank you people of pawnee
i just came down here to tell you how
much i
appreciate your passion you've been
heard
loud and clear you convinced me
jj's can stay
i just have one more thing to say pawnee
psych
do you think i care about how much you
love this stupid diner i bought it for a
song and i'm gonna sell it for a mint
and you can all just sit there pulling
on your puds
oh yeah give me your booze i am
nourished
by your hatred i should also let you
know you're all trespassing on private
property
release the hounds what hounds the
hounds is an fda-rejected cologne i've
been working on
that makes everything smell like wet dog
make it rain
[Laughter]
i gotta go kill my dad let's go
you